si c'est la section de légumes racines
avec les céleris raves aussi c'est le
bloc des crucifères l'écrit ci par là ça
comprend les choux et les choux-fleurs
6,7 gros clubs des lettres ce feuillage
hong kong un groupe qui a plus large
beaucoup de passion de connaissances
d'organisation et aussi beaucoup de
travail
ça prend tout ça à joindre breton pour
réussir à cultiver ses huit acres de
terres à olten en estrie un petit
territoire qu'elle possède depuis trois
ans et où elle fait pousser 40 légumes
de 150 variétés différentes
juste d'ascète tard celle là ici le fait
peut-être un demi arc
je pense qu on a quinze différentes
variétés elle fait partie de la centaine
de fermes de famille certifiés bio du
réseauiq iter il y en aurait aussi une
trentaine d'autres hors réseau la grande
majorité de ces fermes fournissent des
paniers de légumes directement aux
consommateurs qui leur demande
johan nourrit 130 familles nous ont fait
vingt semaines de paniers d'été en fait
trois livraisons de paniers d'automne
fait qu tu es notre mise en marché leurs
moutons les familles avec nous ayons des
légumes de la mij jusqu'à la fin des
temps après 20 ans d'existence le
concept des petites fermes qui livrent
leur panier reste modeste au québec mais
il continue de croître
selon équiterre une dizaine de nouvelles
fermes s'enregistrent chaque année
l'organisme aime se définir comme l'
agence de rencontre entre petits
agriculteurs et amateurs de produits
biologiques locaux
et puis 3-1 ce à peu près mais le
famille de plus chaque année
en fait l'année passée à peu près 2000
familles qui étaient abonnés
bénéficiez des paniers bio cette année
c'est à peu près 13 mai les fans il sait
le 70 une période où si tu as fait un
bond à fait que l'étude des leaders ont
notamment pour ront cantal ou poireaux
sellerie brocolis carottes tomates
salades choux raves et ceux où l'on dise
combien ça c'est 24 de leurs nous pour
le format simple les paniers ce qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est que quand je
débute ma saison chez que j'éteins
d'inscription jeu ça fait donc tendre
venue tant de légumes qu'il faut que je
sorte affecté ça c'est ma stabilité
en plus de ces paniers johan van s'est
produit au petit marché de racine en
estrie où elle va chercher l'autre
moitié de ses revenus cette année ses
ventes y ont augmenté de 25% par rapport
à l'an dernier
t les gens y viennent pas je s'acheter
des légumes le il vient de rencontrer
leurs producteurs c'est ça aussi avec
les paniers de rencontrer des gens de ce
marasme enneigée il ya un visage
derrière leurs légumes quitter les
enfants qui grandissent ça mange à nos
légumes c'est pas ces légumes de nature
de ses relations directes avec les
clients sont un gros avantage tant du
côté humain que financier
johan sans être riche est capable de
vivre de son métier elle fait aussi
travailler quatre employés au moins six
mois par année
la fed qui a pas d'intermédiaire entre
nous puis le client
on oppose les fluctuations qui peuvent
avoir ce qui va en gros puis on peut pas
se faire qu'au physique vannes parce
qu'il ya du brésil devenir un petit
agriculteur et en vivre n'est pas facile
pour autant
d'abord il faut trouver une terre
propice à la culture à prix raisonnable
de 2013 à 2014
leur prix auraient augmenté de 27% en
moyens d'y jouer en ce moment les terres
qui sont à vendre ça va des superficies
halle de 100 acres de 200 arc des fois
c'est même plus que ça aussi qu'on n'a
pas besoin de ces superficies là puis
des terres de petites superficies
beaucoup avant la terre qu'elle a acheté
fait 90 acres et 70 sont en forêt elle
souhaiterait pouvoir en vendre une
partie mais c'est impossible parce que
la commission de protection du
territoire agricole interdit le
morcellement des terres pour protéger
les zones vertes
équiterre essaie de convaincre québec
d'apporter des changements à la loi
on a démontré dans les récentes années
que les petits projets d'agriculture
biologique de maraîchage de proximité
qui peuvent être très lucratif même
sonner toute cette surface
l'organisme espère aussi que québec
finira par aider les fermiers de famille
a payé leur certificat bio comme aux
états unis celui de joanes coûte 700 $
par année
mais malgré les défis équiterre est
optimiste pour l'avenir de la profession
l'espoir est là parce que dans les
écoles d'agriculture on dénote une
augmentation notamment cégep de
victoriaville où le cours d'agriculture
biologique en maraîchage et et complaire
dans cinq ans joint ne se voit avec une
ferme encore mieux organisés offrant des
produits encore plus diversifiée
mais pas question pour elle de prendre
de l'expansion elle met déjà assez
d'énergie dans son métier c'est vraiment
dit de persévérer et dit croire qu'il y
mettre l'énergie folle parce que sa
forme pour ces quelques conseils à la
relève
avant de retourner à ses nombreuses
tâches un travail intense mais c'est mon
plafond clcr jouanno nous changerait sa
place pour rien au monde